chers amis
chers amis bienvenue à ce congrès
fondateur et merci du fond du coeur
d'être venus si nombreux de partout en
france
liberté égalité
fraternité
que la devise de notre république est
belle et combien il est urgent chez
républicain de la remettre au coeur de
notre projet pour la france oui mes amis
liberté égalité fraternité
ce ne sont pas que des mots inscrit au
fronton de nos édifices
face à la crise économique sociale
morale et politique que traverse notre
pays il faut comme l'a fait le général
de gaulle en 1940 et en 1958 revenir à
l'essentiel c'est à dire revenir à la
république la liberté parlons-en
comment croire qu'au delà des discours
fusse-t-il au panthéon françois hollande
soit sincèrement attachés à la liberté
quand ils essayent d'empêcher le premier
parti de france de choisir son nom notre
président nicolas sarkozy l'a bien dit
les gens qui ne sont pas courageux les
gens qui n'ont pas de conviction les
gens qui n'ont pas de colonne vertébrale
essaye de gagner sur le tapis vert il
essaie d'aller devant les tribunaux pour
obtenir ce qu'ils ne peuvent plus
obtenir devant le peuple de france je le
dis à mon tour personne ne doit décider
à notre place de la manière de notre
mouvement doit s'appeler et s'organiser
des socialistes qui n'ont même pas eu le
courage de venir en personne au tribunal
ont pourtant cherché à nous gâcher la
fête eh bien ils n'ont réussi qu'à
renforcer notre conviction profonde
n'en déplaise à hollande valls
cambadélis et compagnie nous sommes bien
aujourd'hui et vous l'avez voter
massivement nous sommes bien les
républicains
cela étant dit il faut être juste il
faut être juste depuis l'élection de
françois hollande il y à un domaine où
les libertés au progresser
ce sont malheureusement les libertés des
délinquants qui grâce à christiane
taubira sont dans nos rues alors qu'il
devrait croupir en prison
non non décidément nous n'avons pas la
même vision de la liberté que les
socialistes
l'égalité parlons-en également les
socialistes ont que ce mot à la bouche
il confond depuis toujours égalité
égalitarisme j'en veux pour preuve les
attaques répétées de peillon puis de
vallaud belkacem contre l'école de la
république qu'il détruise réforme après
réforme
reste donc reste doc la fraternité pour
laquelle ils se sont toujours déclarées
comme les champions toutes catégories
mais franchement où est la justice et la
solidarité
quand c'est l'assistanat qui prenait
quand comme aujourd'hui ceux qui restent
chez eux gagnent parfois mieux leur vie
que ceux qui travaillent parce qu'ils
sont en échec sur tous les plans et
qu'ils sont conscients qu'ils ont abîmé
la république les socialistes ont peur
et ils réalisent ont raison d'avoir peur
quand je vous vois si nombreux ce matin
alors alors merci à nicolas sarkozy
d'avoir su rassembler la famille et
d'avoir créé et dynamique qui comme il
le dit souvent ne s'arrêtera plus merci
nicolas
merci aussi
merci à frédéric péchenard notre
directeur général
il ya nos équipes bénévoles
applaudissons fédéric nos équipes les
bénévoles qui ont préparé ce magnifique
congrès qui vous accueille avec tout ce
matos merci aux fédérations pour leur
travail au quotidien
merci à chacune et à chacun d'entre vous
d'être là et de participer à la création
d'un rassemblement où les militants
auront régulièrement la parole pour
choisir leurs dirigeants et leurs
projets un mouvement vous l'avez compris
gérer aussi avec rigueur et transparence
où chaque euro dépensé sera utilement
dépenser et nous montrons l'exemple avec
ce premier grand rassemblement le
congrès le plus sympathique le plus
dynamique mais aussi les plus chers de
la vème république
le général de gaulle disait soyons
fermes pure et fidèle au bout de nos
peines y est la plus grande de voir du
monde c'est des hommes qui n'ont pas
cédé alors ne céderons rien battons nous
tous ensemble pour la liberté l'égalité
et la fraternité est plus que jamais
chers amis vive la république et vive la
france